hello happy Friday a hug if me and Nick
are back that can only really mean one
thing our second time this week playing
pub G except on a different platform
we're gonna play PC cuz turns out PC got
an update to Nick yeah yeah it wasn't
too big I mean like there's some bug
fixes and stuff I'll read a read through
some of it but you said you got some
extra crates which was part of like the
update I believe
so if you guys played during the times
when there were some issues they gave us
some extra BP that hadn't been
registering I didn't even notice it
wasn't registering I think they sent me
like 2000 BP and there was a couple
extra crates that showed up which is
cool so I'm gonna run through the real
quick list of stuff that are in the
update I will also paste that link later
into the chat in the world they've added
more objects around la Bendita on
Miramar to increase the amount of cover
in terms of gameplay they reduced the
visible distance when parachuting down
in order to test the optimisation of the
server and client performance at earlier
phases of the game items they've changed
to the design of the energy drink I've
seen it it just looks like different
right like oh yeah it looks less like a
Red Bull and more like an UI UX adjusted
the squad team colors players one to
four to better reflect their call out
names yellow orange blue or green
adjusted squad team colors to make them
more consistent between at different
colorblind options they added a function
where a player can select more detailed
criteria what crash alrdy so yep I can't
move and the counter is not counting
okay well go to full camera okay let's
see let me read that again added a
function where a player can select a
more detailed criteria for cheating a
category in the in-game report tool you
can choose multiple items or you can
just report without selecting any of
them replays
while players nameplate is on the H key
now you can check at the current weapon
of the player by pressing the G key you
can add they added a report button in
the replay they added a care package
icon changing effect according to the
status adjusted the replay system so
that now a player can watch the replay
without extra delay in the following
cases solo when the player won the match
when all teammates were eliminated
there's a bunch of bug fixes somehow we
got one anyways just now of which you
guys can read through some of those and
new content they added two new crates
free / paid whatever that means we put
this link in the chat thank you guys all
for tuning in
we didn't even preface this yet but as
we did last time on the stream between
me and Nick kind of added like a little
bit of a gentleman's bet
well not really gentlemen's yeah
basically we're gonna do the same thing
today we're both gonna go I think at
least two rounds each and we're gonna
take the average of those two rounds and
whoever loses will buy the other person
lunch he lost last time so I got a free
gyro from him delicious is the gyro and
fries now let me preface this by saying
I Eric have not played a single match on
PC ever ever only watched go ahead go
check my Steam account do not own it you
ever borrow someone else's No and
whereas Nick has played a good amount
he's gotten some chicken dinners so low
he's gotten some chicken dinners with
some of his compadres compadre so we'll
see how this goes hopefully the chat
believes in me like they did last time
so here we go
does it not up here you got the desert
map here's the other thing I have very
little familiar I'm pretty like not good
familiarity with either map I'm better
sore too I'm I'm better at least in
terms of like where stuff is on this map
compared to like the desert map when I
the desert map there just seems to be
like way more buildings and like just
way more cover and stuff like that yeah
so I'm not I'm not used to that I do
think the the desert map is so much
better it doesn't map it so much better
I don't know desert on console though no
no desert on console I really hope that
they kind of add these changes that
they've done like additional cover
I think the fidelity the map looks
better I think it's a more diverse map I
think there's a lot of like really cool
buildings and really cool stuff I really
hope that it'll it'll make its way well
I hope they spend this map we're gonna
quickly adjust the we're going to adjust
the desert one or this one to be more
like the desert some more cities more
buildings I think it just it's more
excited jiseok says what blasphemy is
this you've never played on PC yeah I've
watched a lot more than I've played the
new can but you know it's fine it's just
how it goes sometimes
although by playing it a little bit it
kind of wanted made me want to play more
I just haven't decided to crawl into
that hole yet because there is some
stuff coming out later this month that I
kind of want to check out Dragonball
Fighters for sure and possibly Monster
Hunter World haven't that that could be
a commitment that I haven't decided on
yet either fear it's the cat don't worry
we're not playing duo's we're doing the
same thing we did last time except we're
checking this out on PC instead because
of the little minor update I guess
there's some no I want rather I would
rather embarrass you it's a more juicy
stream so the stream that now knows that
there's lunch on the line we're both
gonna play two matches each of solos and
the we're gonna take the average of the
two matches unless one of us happens to
get a chicken dinner the other would
have to rebuttal with the chicken dinner
right
that's the stipulation so either the
average or chicken dinner is the Trump's
no yeah Trump's all unless they also get
a chicken dinner in which case that
would be how crazy would that be if
somehow we both got chicken dinner and
had to go into an epic fifth round
I don't think it's gonna come to that I
think I'm gonna die a lot faster I don't
think alright there's more at this table
I'm about to make a bowl say okay
bullets thing I don't think that we
would ever on on the way that we do our
streams here I don't think we're ever
gonna see chicken dinner live Wow
because we focus on like talking about
the updates and like talking about other
things versus like strictly sitting
there quietly and like playing and I
think it's tough because a lot of what
it takes to win is like being able to
hear what's going on around you I'll
give you the audio you know if that's
what you want yeah but I like to play
with like a hundred percent you're
selling yourself short here though
you're basically telling the stream that
we're not gonna be able to do it when I
feel well I don't think it's not
possible but I do think that it's it's
more difficult than some of the other
streamers I like to watch that's fair I
guess but they're also talking and
playing at the same time yeah we'll see
I will say I think that it should be a
good competitive match here hopefully we
we get some kills I will say I'm more
afraid only because I feel like console
even though I played like you know a
handful of times which did give me the
experience the other day I feel like
there was more of a forgiving just like
like bad aim is more forgiving on
console obviously as you guys watched if
you guys were here on was it Tuesday if
you guys were here Tuesday you would've
saw how just how forgiving aim is in
that game and how much you just want to
spray and pray with Auto I guess what's
outside work man and thank you all for
tuning in on the youtubes the switches
and the GameSpot if you guys have
questions or comments I will be here
monitoring chat and once we switch after
next play session here he'll start
reading the chat and stuff like that
while I play and ask questions at the
same time because I still don't know all
the buttons when you jump in on that
Dragon Ball fighters open beta those
aside work man probably hopefully Sunday
that's when open
starts close beta starts today well
tomorrow at 12 a.m. today once said
they're gonna come in and no I don't
think so I think we've decided that
we're just gonna capture footage because
it is a three-day holiday for us and
there's an energy drink there's the new
energy drink design so I don't think
we'll be streaming it maybe I don't know
maybe if I decide that we want to do
something with my friends or something
on the weekend where I can do it from
like home
that would be fine maybe but looking
forward to that as well Daniel Ramirez
asking is it on Steam I'm not I don't
think I don't think Dragonball Fighters
beta is on steam yet I think it's just
gonna be console if I believe correctly
velocity V air I do we do look at chat
so thank you
psidog vlog says hi I think I think
you're awesome
I'm gonna guess think there but thank
you for the kind words I'm gonna assume
that's for both of us
see I don't even know what the
strategies are I just know that circle
means time to run which is which is the
game doing a good job of uh you know
just heard some shots I got some good
you Red Bull and new cases that's the
update there's also some bug fixes and
some other minor things what's in your
rig fellas we have an i7 I want to say
it's a 7700 K 1080 and you know just
your standard I think it's a 32 gigs of
ram you know pretty solid build not a
not a like monster monster but a pretty
powerful PC that's car yes what's up MB
gamer are you today are your Friday when
are you guys gonna play star citizen 3.0
as Tony morandi I'm hoping for next week
I think or sometime after that it comes
down to when Rob's kind of ready he
wants to get a better handle of the game
to try to make it as entertaining as
possible so he just got off playing
World of Warplanes for a couple days to
prep for that shame so he's slowly
playing through stars is and so
hopefully we get stream with that so you
guys can check out that 3.0 update he
was showing me his massive like ship
that he was flying around yesterday I
was pretty cool pub he cost $30 McKell
as red lines
yeah than that down they turned the
bombs up it's kind of annoying on
console to just gameplay girl J GPG
asking what was the best horror game you
ever played for me yeah okay my simple
answer would be PT but I could think
harder than that it's more like
psychological I guess Jake
ball ball ball zong Jake so game so I
was taking good care of y'all then good
to hear yeah they're taking pretty good
care of us
Hemet meg wall hey Bros nice to meet you
again welcome back thank you red lines
yes I'm on the stream yeah we try to try
to give people two shoutouts what's up
afrien Gomes what I want to know and
chat is who you guys think will win this
duo between me and Nick put your ones in
in the chat if you think Nick's gonna
win today or put your twos in chat if
you think I'm gonna win today we're not
doing we were playing solos we're gonna
both play two matches each and take the
average of the two games so right now
he's at 46 so if you happen to die at 46
would take 46 and then whatever his
other match was and then find the median
point there and the loser will have to
pay for lunch probably today because I
don't have lunch probably today sure all
right after this might as well make it
like an experience and if I wish I had
like a bigger periscope falling because
then it would be it's like that
the after-party after the stream you
know like follow us on our journey
Oh like psidog vlogs can you do
fortnight for us on livestream also is
there any way on snipers yes so I'm
actually thinking about diving into
fortnight pretty soon to try to learn a
little bit more about the differences
between fortnight and pub G and like why
a lot of people argued
that fortnight is better than pub G I
think I I don't know I think that
they're I mean I haven't played enough
of both obviously but it's like they
have their differences but their
similarities you know so like I know
like for tonight has like shield things
that you can drink there's also like
crafting your clothing crap thing the
building up stuff your your breaking
through like walls and whatnot to get
treasure and then there's like different
tiers of like weapons so there's like
legendary weapons there's like epic
weapons so that also changes the fight
too which is interesting
oh come on kill him kill him I want him
to die right yes you do yeah I do
oh here comes some of the votes the
votes are coming in a little bit we've
got some I got it's Sohail with a 2
Daniel Ramirez with the two Martin Lee
bow with a 1 Mikkel Matthews with a wine
come on kill him
yeah that's what I need come on just
shocked with the one Hemet what the two
Mike
Mike's no mirrors gaming hub what's up
what's up Mir how are you doing today is
this a solo or duo's why is there two
guys ask Pro to P there's two guys cuz
we generally usually have two people on
stream one person to kind of interact
with you guys on chat and another person
that's generally playing the game just
so we can try to devote more attention
to you guys and not miss anything in
chat oops
I play for night a lot but trust me info
G is much better says Mikkel Matthews
that's fair I mean I'm just happy that
there's two versions of this game and
you can just choose not of this game of
this genre battle John Roberto l
actually there's more than two probably
but oh there's two big ones kind of like
you know MOBAs League you got League of
Legends you got dota it's nice to have
to bury two variants so that you can so
that people find the flavor that is best
for them I guess and if if in the worst
case they can play both as we mentioned
the other day I feel like a lot of it
comes down to you know where your
friends play if you guys enjoy playing
that game together you know that's kind
of the game that I would
soon people gravitate more to towards if
they don't place all those what's up my
he's Jay how are you doing
yeah I've said it before this game I
have so much more joy and excitement and
fun when I'm playing with my friends
versus playing alone but I I don't want
to take away from the fact that I
definitely do play along and I
definitely enjoy it still like just as
much but I would much rather like if
Jake when Jake is here and Jake's around
I would much rather play with Gina or
Robert McCready I don't make margarita
rules is what he says thanks is that's
pretty kind of you um Daniel Ramirez
Xbox one X was actually I ran smooth for
us at least after the update we do not
have any crashes I don't believe not on
stream and I mean the only thing is like
you don't get like the the inventory
management is a bit clunky compared to
PC and obviously aim is not as precise
there's no auto aim so yes no aim assist
so that's what makes it like so
difficult I guess yeah but I mean it's
still good to have it on a platform for
those people that can't play on PC or
don't have a PC oh yeah I'm getting why
are you guys at the SF GameSpot office
asked Jake yes we are we are at the SF
GameSpot office in one of the this is a
stream room that's actually just
normally an office yeah I thought
GameSpot shut down last year nope we
have we have not shut down and there are
no plans baby that's the range maybe you
guys thought the retail no way Game Stop
is not going away
Game Stop is not going away anytime soon
either I don't think they're like one of
the few actual like you know retail
stores are just like strictly selling on
damn that tree was strong which
wildlands had a battle royale mode you
never know arrow I feel like a lot more
games like so battle royale is obviously
the new MOBA or the new hero shooter
like whatever it's like giving you fad
right so I wouldn't be shocked if more
games try to add it as a like game type
or a game mode like that paladin's game
which is like a pretty much like an
overwatch
that's so Cloney though that their their
battle royale is called battlegrounds
paladins battle array or battleground
backgrounds you're like man it still got
paladins in front of it so it's not
totally incorrect now it's just
interesting how they're gonna find a way
to mix the hero shooter genre with the
battle or battle royale genre but hey
they're going for it let's let's pretend
let's pretend there was a hundred person
round in overwatch so it's a battle
royale Oh Oh II see this guy I honestly
thought you were gonna run him over I
did t and then you decided to hop that
and then I was like let me shoot him I
don't think he saw you either alright
didn't chat I was so dumb 38 is it 38
yeah number 38 alright his first round
all I have to do is beat 38 I feel
pretty good I thought you were going for
the long we're gonna do a Yankee Swap
that was very dumb alright you can
adjust it I can switch it back now I'll
keep your settings I'm gonna do like no
hip points either this is this how fast
it is roughly that's fine no is it
slower than that alright but the
question I was gonna ask you before I
brutally blew that mm-hm
was if overwatch had a player on like a
player now it's like battle battle
royale mode who would be the ideal
player soldier soldier 76 it would be
some type of hybrid character or like me
someone that could heal themselves right
like and still do damage would be the
ideal candidate road hog
maybe no I wouldn't pick you can also
heal I would pick road hog oh I gotta
get a gun psych well pre pre nerf road
hog cuz road hog is deafening
so I made it what caps lock why is it
caps lock and not
you can switch it you can switch it if
you want I have little hands it's shift
right normally shift all right here you
know what I have to I have to go I'm
gonna go default I have little hands and
my fingers get tired
no is it shift normally yeah yeah okay
you have to apply when you switch it
yeah
so go ahead default I did hit apply
alright oh you did yeah I did then holds
on fit hold down shift to hold man
thumbsticks is so much easier that's
fine um it's also weird that Crouch is
not control but whatever here here's a
funny fact that I don't really tell many
people but I'll go ahead and just
disclose it to you know the desert map
yeah I screwed know this map so my
outfit that I have set on my character
is um it's really should I go where
should I go that's a cot no picado is a
hot spot I think the power grid San
martín great I'm not and what is this
Emperor what do you think where do you
think where do you think it's gonna
happen at ah you know what I can't tell
you Oh
unless you want me to no I mean no no
it's fine I'm gonna deal with it okay
oh that's a big-ass town I'm not making
an excuse that I use caps-lock
I'm saying I used caps-lock because my
fingers are shorter than everyone else's
that's why I got tiny baby hands and no
Emperor of blood we changed it back to
default setting so I'm not trying to
sabotage oh there's hella people there
dude oh I'm so dead Nick I'm so dead do
you see how many people are landing over
there haha oh this is funny huh I
believe in you dude dude I don't know
dude if this was the other map I would
have landed like in a safer place
alright so it's you and that guy he's
closer to the building so I be careful
I'm gonna help you oh no no no no no no
I don't want it I don't want to hear it
later I think I'm just gonna run I you
know I don't make excuses I might lose I
know I know I know I know oh maybe maybe
runnings not okay we just pretty much
have to hope that I get a gun first
where's the gameplay because I'm gonna
turn it up because you need to be able
to hear
all right let's listen for him dude
we're we're so screwed dude I'm just
running I'm running into some like weird
in first protection
I don't know cuz I press the wrong
button quit hit V V alright now if you
hold alt you can look behind you I'm
holding alt you can look behind you so
you can see if he's chasing your fire
yeah we gotta go
wait worse where's the circle you're in
the circle
alright or maybe it hasn't dropped yet
let me see the map
there you go you're hot Oh is also like
hot bed dude I'm so do maybe the shack
maybe this maybe this lone Shack will
have everything we need so what I was
gonna tell you guys is that uh so before
coming to GameSpot I only played console
games oh it's got a vest and my first PC
shooter was player notes how do I go
full sprint so hit X and put away your
weapons and then wrestle and then is it
x2 rila Requip I just scroll on the
mouse to get right back in yeah it's
very um but yeah I miss her all this
firing dude this was my first PC shooter
ever do 10 people a picado I feel like
there is a placemark though I was
watching a couple stream I'm like flies
you're already at 60 and you've been in
this game I love it
two minutes I love it I'm telling you
there's some hot there's some hot zones
man are you serious yeah but put that oh
it's a suppressor first no no take that
suppressor why because that you can put
on a rifle when you find it okay that's
a real oppressors are so rare that's why
when I hadn't Alaska I was really
excited and I absolutely wasted it
alright we were right in the middle of
it maybe we can go over there maybe the
to the outskirts over there whatever you
think well it's good though it's at
where 53 he was at 38 right you're 38
yeah I will say that I catered my outfit
for the desert map
I don't agree with that why it's greater
cool rock there - um yeah I got that
hopple a six mask just thinking about
song that in the marketplace for like
six dollars I kind of don't believe in
cars all right I feel like we're breadth
of the Wilding it and I'm like I never
used a horse this could be a mistake
though this could absolutely be a
mistake some guy died from falling so
good Pro - I don't know what the rest of
this says only noobs pick up with F lol
I disagree if I see something specific I
want and I look down and I grab it
really quick that's fine but if I see a
pile then I would go in2 tab and then
drag and drop everything what do you
mean only news pickup with f was that
you'd hit tab and then you could see
what you have so hit tab when you're at
like a pile of stuff and then you can
like equipped everything really cool you
mean like that yeah
does headshot kill more than normal
kills yes mr. ninja freak it does
headshots are way better the only thing
that kind of affects it is a level three
helmets those will block those will
block headshots I want them to know I
was here okay we got a couple questions
here I'm watching the chat new TV says
what kind of off topic question what
mics are we using we're using rode mics
they're pretty good Jesus
sorry 20 I think uh you'd have to look
it up always pretty good the
electro-voice re 20 I was right
um no we're not gonna talk about looking
Tobias I don't even know who that is you
know who he is I don't really know him
yes and I abstain as well and then let's
see I'm just checking the shack oh oh
there's a car there where oh no that's
alright you are out in the open though I
would try to get somewhere where you can
get some cover keep wanting to do
frickin e because destiny is e how's
everybody's Friday going if it is still
Friday in your time zone doors look shut
here hang out here I'm at 42 he's
already have 42 you know good I'm just
playing a looting game right this is a
looting game he's definitely gonna win
this one guys so quickly on the desert
map because did you see how many people
there were at that one place like dude
why would why would I land there why
would I even engage so somebody is
asking WRX 420s asking what does the the
new update do so yeah there's a bunch of
nice mostly minor stuff minor stuff so
more objects around la Bendita changed
design energy drink or reduced visible
distance when parachuting down some
replay things are have been added that
see names oh here's a quick little ux/ui
what's the how do i change the rate of
fire B Oh a kak and you already have 760
pub G or fortnight I don't really know
yet I'm gonna try to dive into some I'm
gonna try to dive into some some
fortnight soon to try to see see what
the hype is all about because I died I
just honestly I haven't given a chance
at try to put that suppressor on there
right can you put the suppressor on one
of those oh no you can you know you
can't okay
that's for something else what is does
anyone remember what the suppressor SR
is is that for submachine
because I know there's pistols and us
SMG suppressors and then there's um yeah
he must be really hot in that coat I'm
surprised a circle well you've only gone
through like one circle actually one
circle hasn't even happened yeah I know
that's what I'm saying
and I'm we're at 39 rate it feels good
it's walk how quickly good it died feels
good man
so my fault unreal so my fault you had a
free chance at that one guy and then
didn't do it I did not have a free
chance he totally had that guy you think
he didn't hear me when I rolled up in a
car like okay so when you hopped out of
the car his body was facing well here's
the other way alright here's my thought
process I rolled up hot in the car saw
him before he knew exactly where I was
and I was like okay well he knows I'm
here cuz I have a car so I slammed on
the brakes in order to back up and leave
it would have been like hmm to like go
and buy that he would've shot me so I
was like let me get out take my chances
and blast them didn't have a auto turned
on you always mocked me for that but
yeah well that yeah that's why I'm like
paranoid checking my guns right now look
at me I'm running through the desert Oh
sniper rifle thank you
sr appreciate that so you can put them
in like an SKS or a car I'm sorry I'm
waiting already 37 you know this is so
lame but that's how it goes I'm looting
what do you want me to do I have bad
loot and it's not like I like I haven't
been around some places it's just not I
guess it's just not the hot area Oh
Mykel math is good question are there
microtransactions no there aren't
microtransactions but if you go on the
steam marketplace you can get like
certain items for you get certain items
for like your cosmetic so the way you
look I have bought a couple things like
I bought this jacket and the pants I'm
wearing and it cost me a total of 13
cents so yes there are microtransactions
but they're not really cosmetically
they're cosmetic and it doesn't really
make a difference
yeah and especially with two maps now
like I cater to my outfit for the desert
map don't have a helmet got two pretty
decent guns yeah I do like to scar her
goal is finally closing in I do not like
the Winston that's the one who there is
a Winston okay dog you crazy
I'll use the Winston if I could pick one
up maybe a coop you crazy the Winston is
trash Winston or the Winchester don't
Winchester both of them there's a
Winston actually is it is it Winchester
or not wins Winchester
we're like calling it for the real names
Lee guns I mean there's it's not
microtransaction win him wrong game what
are you talking about you're talking
about overwatch once Winstone oh he's
talking about man goob we had that
conversation like 20 minutes ago
oh yeah I didn't pick up the five five
six mm-hmm or the compensator I have the
compensator I think it's on the ground
isn't it no I picked it oh well I don't
I'm not gonna price night so whose s are
Jarius sniper rifle people are asking
where the lobbies at they're currently
on a little season hiatus there'll be
more news about that soon I'm just
trying to bring in the new year get
everything organized y'all know how it
is like a helmet yeah it's when it's
winchester game looks which chad is
chatting about overwatch damn man
can I get a helmet though nah dawg come
on
I really shocked the I felt like the
xbox circled closed faster but yeah I
feel like around 35 it's when things
start to like slow down on the desert
map
you got a precise number huh well I
think around 35 we got here don't drag
just left-click whoo what's this
left-click
so going is it better than the no no I
would keep the scar I have the scar I
have the scar drop the a K but now you
have two guns with only 5 5 6 so if you
have the a K and then the other one you
have 5 5 6 & 7 6 to get rid of that you
can't drag this out of here what do you
mean nothing
yeah all right make sure you reload it's
good call there you go
yeah I had my scope on it - oh [ __ ] and
reload
I don't play pub G and I'm still
watching because these guys are so
awesome thanks an MB gamer you flatter
us we don't deserve you don't deserve
I'm in the circle yeah yeah I'm sitting
pretty what's them prettier Oh helmet
that's big what's that red dot we need
to read out to you ah what's so funny
everybody's talking about overall oh
yeah overwatch League yeah has everybody
has everybody enjoying the overwatch
League I think it's pretty sweet I'm
pretty impressed with the production
quality pretty impressed by their stares
see right there yeah where's the chat
I'm reading from says Danny and the
twitch chat so we have access to the
twitch and the youtubes
so we'd say what's up to all y'all oh
man when's it gonna get spicy the tab
does not check the entire room but it
checks the it checks like the the big if
you see like it a lot of junk sit in the
ground you can just tab and pick what
you want in it the biker transactions
are not micro transactions you don't
need to use them and honestly they're
not micro transactions because I sell
stuff so like if I get boots that I know
people really like cosmetically but I
think you're ugly I can sell them for
like 10 cents oh I'm strict thing now
we're good so there is no micro
transactions in this game there's a car
there but that looks like it's planted
yeah yeah yeah if it's half on the road
half off you can oh what's where that
package goes
I try to keep running around yeah it's a
good way of putting it
gube and twitch says it's more like an
auction house so you're not buying from
you're not buying from per se like the
developers you're buying from like other
players oh good question
I can't pronounce your name on twitch
but how long do you think it till the
xbox version gets close to this in terms
of like looks and fidelity I think it
goes it has a ways to go because I think
right now they're more focused on PC
more maps for PC fidelity for PC and I
think consoles taking it level 2
consoles taking like kind of the back
burner uh-huh
Felix the Cat wants to know what I got
TAFE for lunch the other day because I
lost the bet I got you euro a hero with
some Mediterranean taco Mediterranean
taco with some delicious fries the best
fries in San Francisco I might say
thanks it's pronounced Mambo leo
ah okay thank you nope yeah let's drop
it Raul wants to know how long we played
pub g4 so Jay claims he's never played
so this is his first match on PC I've
logged probably like 85 hours I think I
don't have a nice I don't have a PC at
home at that on is it better on they
take care of the scar scar probably
scarred they've adjusted the recoil
that's a bad
um I don't think there's too much of a
delay for what versus twitch versus
YouTube twitch is a little bit faster
anything in terms of charity a little
family but yeah so taytay's not play
this game as much was close
Jake Decker and I play a fair amount in
the office Michael hi um and I play a
fair amount Justin hey wall Jimmy thank
from tech we played a good round last
night I blew it
it was me versus one guy and I hit tab
instead of sprint total embarrassment
that's why you should have it on shift I
know I know I I actually had that
pratfall process where I was like I
think I just shot myself in the foot
because I have Sprint's on capslock
instead of shift okay
so we're sitting pretty man we're like
right outside how do i mark the map left
i right-click sir yep so we're pretty
much here we can try to look for Strax
crag later stragglers they're trying to
come up the hill to play it like real
slow here's a question for chat what do
you guys when you're playing pub G what
do you prefer
do you prefer to time scope I rather
have a two times red dot sight or the
what do you call it the other one not
that one the holo holo sight thanks
where do you think they're gonna be
coming from the other side
hey Felix the cat wants us to make this
a regular competition reoccurring it
could get expensive for Mimi's taste so
much better at games than I am but I
would love it okay so that car is
awkwardly placed that car would not be
normally sitting there
feel like someone's gonna roll up from
behind though like hell I kind of agree
with that would be cool to have skins
for guns no let's just not go down that
territory like why do we need to have
that but yeah it doesn't need it I think
this game what this game needs is more
Maps yep more maps and honestly I think
what would be really cool is honestly if
there were a smaller map with the
circles that comes in quicker so that it
would be like a 15 minute game versus a
30 I hear gunfire some guy just died
you're saying Hayes playing it safe and
he should because that's how you win
blunts you play it safe well I mean I
would fight somebody it's just I don't
see him so and I feel like we have a
tactical advantage right now we're like
sitting on the hill here we're like
right on the circle we don't have any
painkillers well annoying
so we're getting some votes for hollow
sight and they don't like the red dot so
I have a sick thing I prefer the red dot
to the Hollow
I think the hollow has too much stuff
going on it's too busy so soon might as
well be boosted up here 25 now yeah this
game doesn't need a solid anti-cheating
system that was included in this update
yeah better better reporting system is
what's in this one yeah um roll wants to
know what our names are on Instagram we
don't really use Instagram he's Twitter
primarily mines real était well you know
buddy took mine already
- Nick margarita yeah I agree with the
army wolf here I always drop on Twitch I
always drop my hand get on the Xbox
version so I have less a cycle through I
agree with that I don't like I don't
even like having a pan sometimes what's
weird that I'll let you like
what's up Robo taco or you come on close
the circle dude someone's got a roll up
from behind right yeah I'm with Jacob
Armstrong on the YouTube I my most
favorite thing is the two time skill
that's like my favorite dying alright
[Music]
how many recorded wins I think right now
Jake and I have we've a fair amount of
solo or not solo I see a car you see it
yeah you can't we have a fair amount of
duo wings
probably more than you oh god we gotta
go dude how did that car know that it
was gonna be over there I think he was
just moving I think he's lucky he's
still moving you see there's that a
second one I think it's the second car
over here you don't see me careful
careful
his eyes are on the prize uh I can send
you guys the link to the patch notes can
I just dump it in here yes it work let
me copy and paste that for you guys
pretty far over he's trying to go he's
trying to wrap around I think and then
you got a motorcycle up top there you
know it's getting hairy
honey pieces in oh so go to the YouTube
tab do and then do it on the bottom
there I'm gonna post in the link on
youtubes hopefully he doesn't see me
from one thing there you go in uh the
youtubes and then I guess I can put it
in twitch too and this is gonna be real
sketchy dude yeah so that uh that link
Oh give you guys the full breakdown on
what the update entails all right
fifteen hopefully we get a kill that's
all I'm hoping for at this point do you
guys think that the game will come out
in ps4 after the Xbox time to Casey I
don't - I do I think so just a matter of
time probably MB game we ought to know
Oh behind me behind me I'm not sure
I think behind me yikes yikes run run
run run run and run run run run um I'm
in the circle he wouldn't be if he was
behind me mb gamer wants to know if we
play csgo michael hime from our tech
team does he plays with his boys from
back home he's pretty good maybe one day
maybe one day he'll stream that I'll be
fun oh there we stop oh no he's gotta go
he's going around he's not in the circle
right now question is is that guy still
behind me or was that the guy right
there he not dead he not dead he's
getting but he's not dead he was pretty
far away anything near that tree he's
out now but I don't think he's looking
at you know he's looking at those guys
yeah yeah maybe we can flank him
we'll just go all the way around here no
j-bone you didn't call it he's not dead
what he said he said I'm calling it a
night I might get killed it's possible I
like to do the serpentine to give the
shakes and the bakes it's so much better
than like the serpentine stuff works a
lot better Wow
are you kidding me you're getting so in
this rocky with the steroids you're in
the middle of the circle oh well we're
gonna again the fray here though in a
second I think you magnificent funny
comment
you see anyone no don't forget the
circle still wide like it's not it's not
tightening yet it's still pretty wide
how much time do we have
123 till it moves so it's pretty what
you're in the circle but there's still
123 before it like confined down to it
to where we're at before shooting you
for done well he should be from down
though I know he is terrible aim
[Music]
Dean is it worth getting Xbox yet if you
don't have gaming on PC yes it is I
think so that was a little
nerve-wracking
alright eight so you have a sock a
ghillie suit man that sucked
I'm sorry guys all right that sucked you
just beat me by like what 30 all right
so you came in ninth fire my gun I
didn't even get to fire my goddamn gun
ah oops got the score 38 tonight sorry
guys I was not entertaining I was my
first game on PC not bad but obviously
it would have been nice to kill a couple
people that was that was booty yeah hey
did you change this I needed to man
I know everyone could be like what is he
doing God I didn't do anything those you
know evil I mean other than maybe
arguably making some right moves I would
have liked to have gotten a couple kills
or at least like see them it didn't
matter if I laid down there or not
IRA trolley or thali the other guy came
from the other side so all he had to do
go was go prone and he would have been
fine you think so oh I don't know I feel
like that guy saw me though oh well that
was a different guy that was no guy the
guy that rule he rolled up behind me
yeah that's how solos go though I play
similarly okay
I don't yeah so solos are such a
crapshoot because you can like spend
like 30 minutes like getting the best
gear and whatnot and then you just get
sniped from someone you don't see and
you can't be revived that's why I like
duo so much better I'm a little salty
after that man I felt like get up pretty
this map is we had a chance there to get
top 5 I think that what happened was I
didn't have his beautiful eye instead of
going down and getting shot by that one
guy I really should have just went
forward impressed that one guy that I
saw that got out of the truck but that
could that might have been the ghillie
suit guy and it might have been hard to
kill him yeah I might've been hard to
see him the ghillie suit is is like the
best thing ever it really is Thanks
rahul tiro Toit chromo for telling your
friends it's up to the channel thank you
oh so say I'm tried to boat out there
and there's like an invisible wall you
can't oh there is yeah that's straight
up like it'll like I love and power but
I know the flight path yeah I mean the
mines tomorrow the update came out
yesterday it's a kind of a small one
just some minor minor changes that that
was a rip I think I've never been a camp
on Millar but militar but it's like so
far away that if I if I get to see and
I'm like where do we end up we ended up
like near Juma something I missed what
it said there
[Music]
but alright up there's one person there
they're going somewhere hopefully you
don't have a that bad luck like I did
where there was like just a bajillion
people I'm surprised I lived through
that to be honest I think everyone was
scrambling to get a gun instead of like
running and I was looks funny that I'm
not gonna get my my solo when the other
day was like I didn't have I didn't have
any I all I had was a pistol until the
final like minute where I found in
mini-14 I found a mini 14 and an m16a4
and like other than that this looks like
a pretty good spot if there's only two
of you yeah I feel like I should oh my
god there's one guy that another are you
kidding me oh he's coming for you he's
coming for me
yeah he's coming for you totally saw
whatever you guys basically cross paths
what will knee where were the other guys
it was net land the link here I'll put
the link back into chat that shows you
all the updates there's a you know atom
or objects around love and detail Amir
Martin Cruz cover reduce the visible
distance when parachuting down to chest
optimization change the design of the
energy drink and changes to replays
there's some changes to squad UI bug
fixes and better reporting for cheaters
but I'm gonna shut up because there's a
guy near here so yes is already not good
that guy wants to hunt you or not have
you got a good Gunny well thanks oh if
it was me I probably just keep looting
and then head to like another area or
something I mean this this is all I'm
gonna do if I can find anything the
swallows pretty big a lot of buildings
to leave what a poor showing
what's apportion my 9th not doing
anything
Wow let's kind of all the game go
sometimes I guess I'll try to try step
it up next game and I'm gonna get a
little hot and heavy over under 50 alive
for Nick says go let him roll you that's
what the internet does so far just to
reiterate me and you nice the suppressor
me and Nick are doing a little friendly
competition the loser will buy lunch
it'll be based off of how far one of us
gets our average sorry
chicken winner will jump off so far in
our first two matches
I got a ninth you got a 38th I think is
what it is so we'll take the averages of
those two he's gonna have to really pick
it up here or I'm gonna have to really
throw the next game yeah anti cheaters
you say that's cool yeah I also read
some reddit article today about how like
pub G players want more like players
from China like banned or something I
guess they're they're doing some
excessive cheating I did not I honestly
wasn't looking to me I don't I don't
know is this this seems L as I uh-oh
is there a cap on how much the lunch can
cost
yeah we're I mean like we're not having
like a crazy lunch we're what it's about
like we do about a 10 10 ish 10 to 12
you know well around 10 plus tax or
whatever it's very expensive here and
yeah yeah it sounds ridiculous but
that's welcome to SF averages it's
cheating bad on xbox I didn't notice
that ya know I think that there were
probably more cheaters on PC than there
would be on Xbox it's hard to cheat on
console
so where are you going to like the
outskirts er yeah I like to I like to
work the edges and that's what I did
poorly that time I was like smack dab in
the middle of that and I also think the
flight path wasn't really near up here
oh so you're going to the camp the one
that you wanted to check out yeah I've
never been to the camp it looks pretty
sweet already hopefully this thing will
knock this down I am a little spooked
though because I think people might be
here you think that they went up and
like your original strategy except they
actually I think I think people may have
I think people may have I don't like
this already seems to be a fair amount
of items here so maybe okay okay I
prefer the a K I know that is not going
to be a popular decision but if you
don't like to snipe I don't personally
like this an IV I mean like I don't even
know what sniping would be like on the
bullet drop for me Forex scope that's
not um the bullet drop I just I don't
have a good grasp on it you can use
keyboard and mouse on Xbox I think there
are ways to do that
blasphemy mom mumbo leo
that's so like I everyone does but
definitely there are probably people
that do it it is what it is man F those
people that do that I hate yeah that's
yeah it definitely is an advantage but I
mean like it is what it is oh god don't
kill me while I'm doing this
get me faster no or vet find a better
spot what's the update uh
as mentioned bug fixes two new crates
for there was a reason let me go read it
where is it
but mainly it's a better reporting on
cheaters it's mainly about that and the
changes the design of the energy drink
also changed like some UI stuff for
squads to make it look make it easier
for people to to know yeah different
colors different colors different ways
to differentiate yourself in
replays is really important they also
added more objects around lab and DITA
on Miramar to increase cover demonic on
the roof but I don't think you can climb
up there where do you think the next
circle is gonna be wow there it's all
right down to 49 so looking good already
it's a lot of loot here to you yeah I
actually think that no one came up here
yeah well I mean I'm sure they thought
the same thing you did which is like
that's really far up if we get caught
and have to come back to it like it's
gonna be like what if it's like really
far or whatever you know I don't
Lorenzo three four five saying
cross-platform needs to be a thing I
don't think you want that no I think
that PC will wreck wrecks out of two out
of two or four no I want to yeah I'm not
a huge fan of the longer scope just cuz
it's why harder to use or hard to get
used to to you so much better
hopefully it's two two two two two is
that another four oh my god yeah nope I
don't like car I don't like to ask and
you shall receive
nice getting getting good loot sir ah if
I die early you guys are gonna kill me
well I don't think anyone's gonna come
up here I have a dank load out right now
I honestly don't think anyone is gonna
come up here so Nick's sitting pretty in
terms of his loot my the only things
that they're really upgrade are getting
like level 3 stuff but amazing Lew can
get smokes his 10 yeah I know I know
eight Meritage says compensating a cane
silencer on m16 that's his advice yeah
why the Xbox don't have this map as
pinch lor I think that it's just not
done yeah and I think that considering
all the framerate drop stuff with the
original map I would have to imagine
Miramar has like way more stuff that
could cause that so I'm sure they
probably have to know this look at this
amass has
so much more to offer it is so much
larger no but that's the problem
oh yeah it's definitely the problem
thirty times holy guacamole this is
freaking scope city up in this so I
guess you just had to come up - oh hello
- Miramar or not Miramar I see the
military camp and I thought the m16 was
better I prefer the scar I think the
scar has less some has less recoil okay
so you're okay got it
preference here he's gonna go scar a km
all right let's see feeling I should
chill for a minute I think so
41 alive doing almost as good as the
first round Nick yeah I find that like I
guess because people aren't as familiar
with this map yet I mean it has been out
I don't know why you see how many people
died just now I mean like I'm sure they
just go to the same spots maybe but
there's so much stuff in here - yeah sir
is pretty lipped look at all the helmets
this is whack this is a military base oh
so which one is better range okay has
more recoil than m16 m16 has the highest
muzzle V low why is he running obviously
it direction of the circle we're
technically in the circle David duponte
yeah we do this one that we're on the
outskirts right now flat the flash hider
is overall better does the same thing as
a compensator - nice
somewhere crisp app saying set one to
auto or set it to auto are wolves
weather if you're hot and have a coat
you'll be more prone to heat stroke rain
and stuff like that someone said their
kingpin for 20 says is it level 3 bets
on the other side of the door what door
that's too late now why I was in that
whatever you do you are you sure I think
it was a lot - I walked over it ok can
you play this on Mac Mac yeah ok
read read rule yeah
it's like RC Cola now yeah it does look
you gotta stop Luton man why it's all
about getting uh that's what it's about
though part of yeah well yeah no he is
true he is he is right like the amount
of stuff that I have I really should
stop moving and like camp out but I
don't want to be a boring stream for you
guys let's try to get some litt gear you
have lit gear though I know I've look
here I don't know how much like you know
like I said the only thing you're really
missing is level 3 stuff and maybe some
more boosts but I mean other than that I
think that like you couldn't really ask
for more maybe a ghillie suit no it's
only gonna come out of a box or package
rather all right the blue is starting to
or at least come in once all right so
you're pretty far it's moved a little
bit
um do I go back to my vehicle chief Tom
Tommy says once I get a decent gun I go
straight to the center of the circle
that seems like a risky play but if it
works for you it works for you they
remove the rain in the fog Maps and
that's probably too much stress they did
I don't know I've said some Meritage
that probably getting reworked I guess
um you need a ghillie suit I don't know
if I want to stay on foot or oh man your
bike is somewhere there right you left
that bike over there where did I leave
it
oh it could be ghillie suit right there
okay you're not gonna go after that box
let's be real here you got to have a
monster round here we're gonna drive in
look would you see how the you see how
the fence kind of moves around
I just flinch so hard it's so funny the
other day after we had been playing xbox
I was playing on I was playing on PC in
front of you by the way yeah I see I see
I'm just watching for people I had said
to Tay I was like dude look at how hard
I'm shaking and as I said that and I
showed him how hard my hand was shaking
rip he died he literally was looking at
his hand that shot headshot
one one-shot kill single sniping with
the m16 is the best with the 4x as watch
Ryan I don't know man I haven't played
enough the 4x stuff like that the longer
scopes intimidate me me too
I'm used to the Call of Duty at short
range scopes so
all right he's heading back into the
circle on the main road no F's given no
fear that will doom bug you there oh
yeah no no no no no no Adam did you see
how hard I flinched that's scared get
him come on oh oh where is he coming
from
get him how does he have that kind of
range all right like an 8x scope damn it
you would have got a free lunch like for
sure if he died you see how hard I
flinched yeah I did that scared the [ __ ]
at him you gotta be calm and collected I
think you should go first aid somewhere
yeah I know
oh you got 40 seconds though until the
blue that's already I'm already in the
circle but can you put an 8 X on an m16
on the pc version yeah I think yes yeah
I think so I wouldn't suggest that was
so close Nick real talk like you were on
death's door almost I wish she died
there then it would have been no stress
we could have just yolo swaggins the
next round now we have to play legit and
as Nick would say boring I don't know
you're not on the outskirts though huh
you're kind of like in the so I was up
there last time I think oh there's a Oh
[Applause]
show me how he died how do you think is
behind you he had to be right like that
was like really it sounded really close
it sounded really close Nick alright
what was that 26 okay you had the dune
buggy he's going up the hill you are
probably bandaging at this point did we
not hear this thing at all I didn't hear
me at all I didn't hear any I heard
nothing
he knew do you think this was the guy
shooting yes sure you followed me follow
look at this play look at this sneaky
play goodnight alright 24 and 38 so no
it's 20 24 25 yet
I'm not happy
what's the average of uh I'm not happy
what's the average of 25 and 38 like 29
know like 30
that is why I don't like soullow hey
here we go
that's why I don't like so someone do
the math for me I'll give you you know
what now it's finally give you one round
after this to end the stream yeah yeah
unless I go the distance here 31 so
alright 31 people are saying 31 31 and a
half will round to the average I know
you just take both and you divide by T
right cuz I hate you I don't know what
did I get tell me you had a 38 and 2530
1.5 so we can just round to the the
better number right which is 31 I'm not
gonna lie I'm pretty salty right now
this is the first time that I'm like I
really hate that I always salty I didn't
hear him at all I don't think any of us
did I didn't even hear it I didn't hear
the buggy that's for sure how do I not
hear him he literally pulled up to the
tree he didn't pull up to the treaty
pulled up to down there he pulled up
close enough that I should have heard
him yeah
yes course yeah well he has a silencer
on his car dude did you know that was a
new mod I'm just kidding oh can you fix
the king jiggle the there's a little
splitter down there yeah there you go
guess I'm not getting right here you
getting out no I'm gonna keep tearing up
yeah that's good yeah it's moving when I
let go that's mine let go I'm you good
yeah I'm gonna go yeah nobody heard the
car so yeah not happy with that one 1 2
1 2 that one if I was if I was at my
desk I'd be really bitter
hey somebody do the math for me what's
the worst I can do while still getting
31 during us so let's say you let's say
you came in 50th so 50 plus 9 equals are
we not even over the man dude if you
come in top 50 you still won where's the
map oh there I am and you come in top 50
you're still here I'm gonna go to that
base
[ __ ] except I don't know where that base
is which one see that to that base you
love so much I was let a lot of stuff up
there that was real lit there anyone
around me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no I I admit
defeat there's nothing I can do I mean
the first game is my wall I won't try to
camp it out how about that I'm not gonna
I'm gonna loot but I'm not gonna like
you know uh I mean what do you gotta
come in like just play smarter I don't
know don't play dumb err rather dumber
no it would be dumber oh oh oh
mistake mistakes were made Nick I'm
going somewhere else no I don't do there
saying that like because there's only 89
people and you're playing it no it
doesn't matter I'm giving him the better
number yeah 89 or whatever doesn't
matter what why what is it what can it
be
so it's up to a hundred alive and so
this particular Lobby only has 89 people
alive
oh no I'm using your keys oh yeah it's
which is default yeah sorry fudge
switches switches nah I just got to play
through it
no Switchfoot's gotta play through it
there's too many people over there I
know some guy got a scar and killed like
three people wait ow yes there's a scar
right there is there where oh that's a
book huh Nick are you sabotaging me
switch your controls I don't have time
to do that you have plenty of time
there's no one over here dude I'm afraid
lay down with Ronan those bushes said a
helmet mmm-hmm
take it just camp and walk away and
still win I'd have to find a good spot I
mean let's be real here setting setting
settings
I'm salty I had sick here dude I'm gonna
have the choice right here it's all
right Nick it happens
you check the Lucha Libre thing over
there no I kind of quick peeked into the
center and I saw nothing okay really I
saw a gasoline tank and I was like nope
I'm good
gasoline yep um let's see I think he's
already won 64 now frying pan yep that
might save us all right oh I think you
won really we're at 60 plus 9 get a
frickin gun though all you got to do is
survive like three more people 59
hae-won's damn really over that fast
yeah man we do the averages of three
games no time is that 1212 alone it
depends on how fast I die I guess y'all
y'all gonna be bored the frickin gun
though no no he's the one yeah he's at
34
okay I wasn't sure if I was hearing
footsteps they're mine come on yo gubin
twitch you want to go head-to-head dude
you let him get to you so easily yeah
why he keeps coming after you go - got
it we have no frickin weapons poor grip
sure this is not good Nick doesn't
matter cuz you've just won it's over
okay it's official well I'm still gonna
try to do our best here for the stream
do I have
dude gave me a frickin gun
everybody st. best of five best of five
FS a five right that's what I'm saying
like yeah gun no he doesn't he own a gun
dude I don't have a frying pan he's a
smoker naughty piston there's so many
people at the freakin military that like
hey go hey John
nope you don't want it what are you
doing
ar is smg's snipers or bust god
oh wait what's that that's a machete I'm
a chicken dizzy death in twitch Kubo's
me lunch what gu bored he owes me lunch
for those chicken dinner bets really Yad
when Jake and I played duo's here I
played on the gaming PC and Tate or not
- Jake played on the main PC here goob
said that we couldn't get in the top ten
and we almost won but it was the last
match of the day yeah you know you owe
me two chicken dinners that's right we
shouldn't made you pay we're a PSX damn
well - oh yeah nice dude this D Oh car
98 snipe ah you guys ready to witness
the amazing sniping skills of Eric tape
I better off just spray and praying with
my
uh a D Azur I have a question for your
Co oh my god the circle is so far away
really it is so far away we need that
that left minivan that sucks All Balls
eighties or I have a question for your
follow-up he said when you you need to
rush once you've found to a one or two
good guns where are you saying you rush
to them where is that truck oh there it
is
god this car worst car in the entire
game is right here I don't even know how
to drive the van oh there you go if I
could die in this thing oh my god is
struggling yeah
go faster you just this thing is no
bueno off-road too
we gotta cut across and make it through
these hills through the hills oh god if
we can make it up there Jake and I did a
test video you guys should definitely
check out that feature on YouTube and
site I think it actual test video though
we did we did best practices for the new
desert
um well Jake did it I just helped him do
some of the tests and there's some
interesting stuff like I drove the truck
wall he drove this thing and it was
really funny like going up hills and
stuff it's actually the worst vehicle
yeah but it does take a lot of bullets
as yellow Sanchez which is true it's a
tank
it's the Odyssey baby the Honda Odyssey
dizzy definite which cuz it's the
Mystery Machine it does have the correct
color scheme I shift equals boost if you
want but it makes your it diminishes
your uh gasps bastard that's fine we
don't care about gases also eight ad is
saying that once you have two guns you
should rush don't camp
I get it I get you talking about us or
in general no just in general like
that's his strategy oh god we are so far
away still the circle moves super slow
they're saying I should be looting um me
yeah no I'm saying I should be leaving
like that a little like Cathedral
looking thing just back there Mauro
wants to know do we play other video
games so I'll just tell you what other
games I'm playing currently I'm
currently grinding in Mario Odyssey
trying to get all 999 moons I think I'm
only a hundred off and I'm not using any
guides I'm also playing overwatch just
because watching the pro stuff got me
back in um what else are we playing in
the office not much Oh
couple guys are can't give me any
details on it but a couple guys are
playing a little a little game called a
monster hunter so be on the lookout for
some exciting stuff coming from that
that's gonna be a while yeah it's gonna
be a while but yeah some guys are
playing the new Monster Hunter world I
believe Joey and the boys is gonna be
doing some DBZ at home this weekend
maybe recording some hot some hot
gameplay for fighters what else still
have yet to finish the breath of the
wild DLC this seems like such a bad idea
where is that package gonna land it's
gonna land right near you I think cuz it
doesn't dropped where is it did it drop
already like it must have dropped right
away I don't see ya oh there's a way I
see people saying stuff about the the
jump rope moon in Mario de si it's a way
to cheese it there's a way that you can
cheese it I use the scooter and I did
the jump rope challenge I got up to like
201 with the scooter what are you done
don't know loot crate crate dogs you got
out in the middle of field people's
accuracy man I like go up a hill hunker
down heal up and we saw what we saw how
those change he runs through it was a
car he runs through a field to the cars
like the car right there
Oh red circle that's not good I have a
lot of time right is that with that
flute no no you're out of the circle and
it's coming for you and you're also
gonna get bombed
how much time do I have it's coming
that's like right there yeah yeah that's
so slow
hey is good at zigzagging does Felix the
count do I get in the car
oh god Nate bomb time he cradles Steve s
this dis boy cray just boy cray cray I'm
dead he'd be running through the bomb
field when I die in the bud no no
weapons and there's a car right there so
somebody's here oh god it's getting
hairy
you gotta get inside I know Watchtower
will save me dead guy
lots of dead guys loot their bodies oh
my god there are so many dead bodies
here do you see that yes Oh many more
days many good dude
you best be careful cuz who's ever in
here is really good woah or they're all
gone oh they all dead you're gonna have
to move in about three minutes again
holy cow ten bodies here I have no mini
bullets though can't try the tractor
alright one gun takes five five six the
other gun takes seven sixteen you don't
have any five five six if you scroll
down you can see both those boxes so no
one has any sit five five six go to
those other boxes down the hallway do I
have a level two yeah yeah oh my god
there's some stuff going on here
alright scar in front of you what you
need is what you need is ammo you don't
have any five five six
yeah you don't have any ammo for that
though
okay it the circuit level to vest right
there I think or those pants oh it is
best damn Hacienda de patron was lit af
earlier in the game always level three
back at level three bastard [ __ ] we
gotta go
you need ammunition though for the five
five six you need the green ammo got it
you have time I'm not I'm good dude I
don't even know where he was whoever
that guy is had wrecked some people
alright let's check the average its
12:22 now the score is currently thirty
one point five is what I have to 32 plus
9/2 alright it's thirty one point five
to twenty point five I'm down ten points
I'll give you a go hold on it oh this
guy this guy has already spent a load of
money he's on the outskirts oh you just
saw my dumbass running out in the field
he's got a car whoa what and then I
thought he was on the other side and wow
he's terrible aim actually alright fair
why no because he killed you he was he
was hacking how do you know that replay
that what do you mean he's hacking
replay it alright what you died when he
wasn't shooting the bullets followed you
sure there's a bullets aren't you sure
that art isn't this delayed that I'm
willing to bet you any amount of money
he's hacking cuz watch so that bullet
hit you sure I'll explain that on delay
he shoots a bunch he hits you once or
twice okay you're still moving it seems
too late though right isn't it just
delay
I don't know man oh it's fine that's how
it always is I think so the rumors that
I keep reading about online is that the
rumors I keep hearing about online is
that the hacking that's been going on is
that you shoot neared them and the
bullets curved to you I don't know I
like every time we've watched a kill cam
it's always been delayed or behind so
it's like I don't that look fine I mean
if he was hacking man that was a he
should get a new program cuz he freaking
whiffed a shitload with his AR I'll
trust Bretty in YouTube he says replays
no I don't want this map I'll play it
what is it is it the whole battle the
old man let me play it let me play it
alright so you go first and I go we're
just doing I fine dude a lot of uh I
trust you guys wait so then if the
killcam is wack then how are you
supposed to report people if you can't
tell like whether they're using that
like the bullet curves or I don't know
who's gotta be a better way I think I
think you would die faster if he was
happy can you
it's wanted as the movie farik's okay
can you jiggle them again and every time
we roll over it it like here yeah it's
good that's Gucci yeah that's good
dust Gucci alright so what is it you're
down ten so I got it like I don't know
I'm down ten I'm just gonna give you a
very good fighting chance here why all
right this map I think it's hard to
reach people know where things are and
there's less big cities let's see
where's your flight path because if you
have a chance go to Georgia Pole it's
like my favorite hello
alright so everyone's saying that it's
delayed we can't go to Georgia Pole
we're just dropping Roz are we're severe
knee or the ruins no one goes to the
ruins are you huh no one goes to the
ruins right new know if you get the
Georgia pole George falls sick like all
those things up at the top have all
those you see all the apartments down to
your left
or death you're right I'm sorry that's
your right oh [ __ ] that's the school
isn't it
no that's the rooms that's why you're
the ruins I know because no one goes
home mixing it up I'm mixing up the
gameplay here have you guys in the chat
has anyone that plays on PC have you
guys experienced any like questionable
stuff I don't know what is questionable
what's not so I can't determine what the
difference are you know I don't see
anyone
oh yeah cuz no one there's nothing at
the role they reduce the visibility
apparently right is what one of the
fixes was I don't think she is at the
ruins last time we got some goodies
I feel like Stewart says I plant PC II
don't mind hackers I just play for fun
never take online serious yeah that's
such a good attitude dev now I don't I
get super competitive salt baby but I do
I do respect that this might be a
mistake yeah I was gonna say dude
there's really nothing here I told you
we're mixing it up I know but like no
one does this as Mike would say we'd
have to throw hands oh here we go
m16 she know about the ruins don't you
[ __ ] on the ruins Nick mr. ninja freak I
don't know what we're saying it's a
common mistake
what is the ruins what's this what's
this what's this are you kidding you at
one time you can have the power of the
ruins you didn't believe in the ruins Oh
what Alistair says that he had a guy
tracking him through the walls that is
definitely a massive advantage okay well
yeah that's when you can like see the
killcam probably and be like all right
that guy's yeah probably doing the
cheating's Dutch sheets flashhider for
an SMG that to level two of the rock
again we are playing pub G on PC
all update small update I was like
yesterday was yesterday or the night
before it was Wednesday from na 6 p.m.
Pacific to 10:00 p.m. Pacific so it's a
pretty significantly long update I
thought it was kind of at an
inconvenient time but that's just
because I was at night I wanted to play
from 6:00 to 9:00 but that's ok well
6:00 to 10:00 I just played on xbox is
done I'm a firm believer that if you do
not have a PC like me and you want to
play at home and maybe level to vest
we're right there and you want to play
with your friends who may be only play
on console playing on xbox is definitely
worth it oh uh Wow
what's it quite so CBT on twitch says
was the x1x
not reliable for streaming it was
actually really reliable we didn't have
one crash when we played on Tuesday yeah
yeah we're good you didn't get any
crashes it also it also looks a lot
better on the on the XP so their their
latest update was more significant than
this PC update and some Goods made some
really good stuff
oh there's no auto huh no just burst
burst and single for those and I have to
give them the old let me change that oh
yeah do change that coat why because
desert map and it's more visible in this
one I'm wearing a black shirt underneath
you we just want to take the coat off
okay
you just drag it off drag it off to the
side yeah
like a scope I don't think you see
anything here primarily when you're in
like ruined areas and you're looking for
stuff they're gonna be on crates and
there are no quittance there hmm do they
have to go to Georgia for Gatka
yes we're gonna go I'm gonna give Nick a
fighting chance
what 3858 we're going I think you're
good because no one lands by the ruins
no but they're gonna be a gecko I'm
going to get go oh let me see him out I
don't know where the flight path was
where should I go Georgia pull the
flight path was this way people are
definitely at George Pole I know that
for a fact
uh-oh Han drew says yesterday a guy ran
me down in a Jeep and when I saw the
replay I don't know how he saw me from
kilometres away cuz he was lying down
the grass not moving yeah maybe is I
don't know the problem too is like that
replay because of how the replay system
is end there there are making tweaks to
it because that's was part of the patch
it's really hard to tell a lot of stuff
especially if there's like so maybe that
guy's aimed wasn't that bad maybe he was
hitting you yeah it spot no but he
missed quite a bit though cuz like he
took off almost half my health with this
night you know and then he was like kind
of like he probably used like half his
clip to kill me there yeah to get there
the remaining 50% raw wants to know why
we're not sniping I think it's just
personal preference Roo I don't have the
confidence to snipe either why I nor do
we have a scope for it the bullet drops
are like they vary I think between the
SKS in the car and okay this is
surprisingly empty any more bandages
like first aid or boosts
and also Steve s is right via salute is
random so you can't really like
cherry-pick snipers destruction just let
me see the next person so that we can
actually so I can actually say that I
died because I lacked skill although I
did do a I'm still doing a dumb maneuver
I feel like just running on the open
also don't forget you guys GameSpot and
Tay pretty much go live every weekday at
11 a.m. Pacific time 2:00 p.m. Eastern
and we stream lots of different games
when there are new releases tape plays
the new game so be the lookout for
monster hundred world soon DBZ fighters
it's a lot of betas next week a lot of
betas next week so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification button so you
know wente goes live we usually stream
with two people so that you know he can
focus on plane these doors are rope no
they're not
I don't know oh they are so yeah don't
forget subscribe if you're on Twitch hit
the follow make sure you get notified
but it's usually run the same time if
you want to get on a nice little
schedule a lot of fun games sometimes
giveaways in 2018 there's a lot of like
new plans for new and exciting things so
be on the lookout for those this is that
house we were in on that Xbox dream well
this house appears like 15 to 20 times
in the map
yep I'll stir you can use alt to change
your to change your path or to keep
running in a specific path and change
your in this vision yep I would assume
whoever was here probably this is you
and probably know per taste Oh an
extender if you want for your gun it's a
quick-draw trick quick-draw and extender
nice was I didn't extend the mag dude
did Sam hell is talking about scum so I
brought that up the other day - yeah I
did a little research it looks pretty
cool I'm definitely going to take a look
the other day nothing well somebody was
here come on Circle tell me where the
next circle is I think the the next
thing I really want to do is test out
fortnight's battle royale and so I'm
gonna have a better like more educated
opinion on which one I like better I
close this door oh it's so slow oh wait
can we go it's further in the Gatka we
just wait til Tomei says I wish Maps had
more lakes rivers for the boats
I think this map has a fair amount of
lake well
oh shut the jiggle that thing again
sorry I think it has a fair amount of
thank you so good yep
he has a fair amount of water on this
one I think the desert map obviously
does it feel like it plays better it
doesn't it didn't really change too much
of the actual gameplay except for like
that one spot on the desert map so
nothing too much in terms of that update
yeah my girl update was definitely for
Xbox I think if you were playing on
console minor stuff
Steve s says 42 people let's go and he
also says go get loot bro
I'm trying I'm trying to find he goes yo
bro get some loot I think you're
following someone's footsteps and
they're doing a good job of closing
doors behind you to think they haven't
done it Twitter account names again I am
Nick margarita spelled like the pizza
not the alcoholic beverage - everyone
adores and Eric it was yours at uoit a
life e y EA y numbers no no disabled -
hey secure that one I don't need that
stuff right and we got like - oh that
scared me that little noise you made
really well because I was looking I was
checking a corner my bet this has been
looted he did a good job little doors
behind you - except for that one except
for that one right there unless I was
already open next pub G stream I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask Tay instead of us doing a
head-to-head competition I'll bring the
gaming PC in here and we'll play duo's
together it's fun fun I won't be able to
help you much - oh wow that car is
abandoned no no it's that's just part of
the environment I don't like that I
don't have a full auto gun right now
we'll turn them first I did know you're
on single Steve s says Nick is the man
no I'm not until I have a good round I
cannot really go that one guy in this
this bathroom right here I do very
chilling right here we like come at us
bro then he came at us
yes Felix the Cat says I think Nick
anoche is in the room where Nick choked
on Tuesday on the stream that is correct
he was oh shoot
inna kill him when he pops out oh he
just want he doesn't want anything to do
with this oh he gone dog hey Sonia's
drowned
what damn I should have lit his ass up
I should just did it huh I should have
hi evil perk are on YouTube what's up ah
a wee verse in says this game is for
knots you meant to say noobs and you
spell wrong and you got him got him
single shot for life Nick knows you're
right CBT I rocked the single shot at
all times I shouldn't but I do
uh and that guy he's probably long gone
Danny says follow that car I'm trying
I'm trying I'm trying you got the drop
on them if it says it restricts it
doesn't actually change the circle till
it comes in right doesn't that change
turtle it comes in Tess come all the way
in before it moves god open-field
running bicycles should be everywhere
plane drop
oh that card that card that card that
car that car all right you got the drop
on them should just steal his car she
says car just bail
yeah no evil pro car we will not buy you
a webcam so stop asking
I don't want to say anything cuz I want
distract I said five seconds oh it's not
moving at huh
well you were too you already in the
circles I know but don't want to know
the next one
didn't went up there I should get in the
house - I feel like getting this car
bail dog cuz these have all been looted
the doors are all open yo what's up
Joshua Lambert I actually went to you on
University and our presents name is
president Lambert huh you think he's
gonna go back to the car you boy
eventually right if you're gonna shoot
from that distance you're not gonna want
to shoot on burst though remember bursts
is for like close
well I can't it be like Call of Duty
we're like it was nice more ammo where
it's like you know where bursts is like
just equally as deadly they're saying I
need use this gun from distance yes
single because when you fire the gun
kicks up the rego eqg ow okay police
guard thank you for the sub thanks dude
we appreciate it
yeah all subs and likes we love them
Tate is a really good job every day of
trying to get you guys you know
interacting with us mmm hanging out dude
look we love giving you guys call outs
all right so needed
kamilla I think it depends on the day
first rains few counts are very sporadic
on you do not know you can't go through
that window it's too tight I would I
would sick
thanks for the sub Joshua we're in the
circle Nick you too homie yeah but that
guy is still here don't forget he's
definitely camping cuz
is this the same town where takeout
killed by the tree that wasn't a tree it
was in a tree as much as it was a it was
a car oh yes yes yes no no wasn't here
wasn't here six to you yeah but you
don't know any guns for it yeah pick
those windows and then get shot by yeah
I don't like the situation I'm a little
freaked a little freaky little two vests
if you don't have one
what's our kill record my highest kills
ever and around was ten but we didn't
win had five on that uh uh yeah I read
the owners of games games stop no for
not you're not well wouldn't that be
like a breach of like interest for us
reviewing games probably yeah yeah yeah
we can't do that that's right because
we'd be like oh this games really good
and then you guys would buy it
we'd give it a really good review man I
should just shot that one guy my
favorite weapon is the scar oh that just
happened well he obviously threw it from
that way so I think so yeah over there
no no he's like throwing this way like
you're saying from there today
no from out there that windows are not
yeah like those window no not those
windows like there yeah
still sitting pretty I guess I don't
like our guns but it's that coke wants
to know will they ever have pub G on
mobile yes they are there's actually a
trailer if you want GameSpot James Watts
youtuber games.com and search pub player
knowns battlegrounds mobile there's a
trailer for that air during the game
Awards now you have no idea how that's
gonna work Wow
immortal says 3 million copies sold on
Xbox that's that's rad somebody's here
like not in this building but in this
town of Gattaca it's only 25 left zero
killed 24 now I think I'd have to win
out right to beat day at this point
mathematically where do you think they
come from though like I guess from here
Oh VSS is pretty dank yeah I do like the
VSS it's at the 8 x go built-in if far
is pretty quick
do I know when the mobile games coming
out I have no idea
I don't know these day I bet we're gonna
have to to move
oh hey we're really yeah this is
ridiculous
are we in it right now no we're right
unbelievable no we're still right
outside of it though doesn't matter it's
catering to your needs
no it's called tactic Oh yikes he's here
aircar - oh there it is don't shoot
don't shoot
cuz you'll tell them where you are and
you don't know why why are you telling
me these I'm helping you this is life
this is I'm not playing a game after
this it's already 12:45 we're done
absolutely this is the final decisions
that I want to make yeah oh god it's
really lit out over there is it I think
it is mathematic well it's not
mathematically impossible to beat tabi
as we said that if I were to win a
chicken dinner that would trump
everything but it's too late we've been
playing for too long already
yeah my calm with you dog Michael uh
Parisot this guy's gosh how do I shoot
him though I don't know that's the
barrel of his gun you know we're gonna
you can go to that one nobody's gonna
see you his hand no no no no no no he
knows all right Oh God
yeah that's not we wanted some spicy
action he's got level three by the way
alright he's just hiding in that room
you can shoot the door down are we in
the circle know or not [ __ ] you gotta
kill him no I don't we don't have a
single kill in the stream you shut your
mouth are we in the circle I'm not oh
the same guy it was not it was not the
same some days you got it you still do
better than Nick no kills that entire
stream none you had a better chance I
did have a better chance that was the
first guy I ever saw like actually
seeing him I guess I could have went in
there Nick jinxed it I don't have a name
Michael if I had an a tall boy would I
have needed the crap out of him
alright we should probably wrap it up
I'm rapping as bad as a bad alright
gentlemen ladies all of our friends on
the youtubes and switches thanks for
hanging out with us on this Friday I had
a good time hanging out with my best
friend Tay here I checked every corner
but that one sorry where we go here
squish camera there's camera sorry we
watch this we didn't do you so hot
did he know I was comin oh you probably
here's a flow that's someone else oh
yeah that is you know he was totally
watching and that is you look at this
chicken he didn't shoot either he's like
oh wait is he coming in in into this
house oh this is smart
this is real smart I'm sorry you guys
can't see it
yeah he just he knew anyway
thank you guys for hanging out with us
oh we had a good time I'm sure this will
happen again I'm now over to IO
teh lunch and I am going to go buy him
that lunch right now any other last
words
now come back next week when day's a
holiday but we'll be back with streams
next week I'm sorry
that was not even a lot good looting we
did Nick and we did a lot of good loot a
lot of good looting all right so you
guys have a good weekend enjoy your
break if you have it
you